Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis à Amsterdam.
[musique]
Alors que ce soit bien clair, la seule drogue qui m'interesse à Amsterdam, si vous m'avez suivi sur les réseaux sociaux, c'est le fromage !
J'aime le gouda. C'est comme ça ! Le gouda et moi c'est une histoire d'amour !
Et si je suis là aujourd'hui c'est parce que je joue une date de mon spectacle ce soir.
Mais j'en profite aussi pour vous faire un Mental Vlog.
Aujourd'hui je vais vous expliquer comment faire un tour moitié magie, moitié mentalisme pour bluffer les gens pour Noel.
C'est un petit peu le thème de ce qui a partout autour de moi.
Mais écoutez bien, jusqu'à la fin, je vais vous donner quelques infos importantes par rapport à ça, et 2, 3 petits trucs pour la chaine.
[musique]
C'est pas un endroit tellement génial pour faire cette vidéo ?!
Pour vous expliquer le tour, je vais vous le faire une fois.
L'idée ce n'est pas forcément de vous bluffer c'est bien de vous expliquer un tour que vous allez pouvoir refaire.
On est pas en combat, on est pas en duel vous et moi.
Imaginez que pour Noel, Santa Claus m'ait donné 20 surces d'orge.
J'ai 20 sucres d'orge invisibles juste là dans ma main.
Vous allez en prendre un certain nombre. Pas bzaucoup non plus, vous ne me videz pas tout le stock, vous en prenez un petit peu.
Vous comptez combien vous en avez.
Et vous retenez combien vous en avez, ça c'est important !
Une fois que ça c'est fait, vous saviez que j'avais 20 sucres d'orge dans ma main, vous m'en avez pris un certain nombre, vous comptez combien il m'en reste.
Et vous allez réduire ce nombre.
Si vous regardez des vidéos vous savez ce que ça veut dire "réduire". C'est-à-dire que si il m'en reste 13, vous faites 1+3.
Si il m'en reste 19, vous faites 1+9.
Si il m'en reste 10, vous faites 1+0, etc...
[musique]
Ceci était l'intermède poétique !
Donc vous savez combien de sucres d'orge vous m'avez pris, vous savez combien il m'en reste, et vous réduisez le chiffre du nombre de sucre d'orge qu'il me reste.
Maintenant vous reprennez dans ma main autant de sucre d'orge que le chiffre réduit que vous venez de calculer.
Si le chiffre réduit c'était 2, vous me reprennez deux sucres d'orge et vous les additionnez aux votres que vous avez déjà pris.
Ca fait des petits sucres d'orge en plus !
Et dans votre main, vous avez forcément un nouveau nombre de sucres d'orge.
Evidemment !
Et c'est ce nombre qui est important.
Parce que ce nombre il est à vous.
Il dépend de combien vous m'en avez pris au départ.
Et pourtant je sais déjà quel est ce résultat.
Il suffit d'ouvrir la main pour bien voir que c'est 11 !
Vous avez 11 sucres d'orge dans la main.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un forçage mathématiques comme certains que je vous ai déjà appri cette année.
3 choses à rajouter pour améliorer tout ça.
Déjà ne négligez pas les forçages mathématiques.
Ca peut etre un bon point de départ dans du mentalisme, pour savoir à peu près où la personne en est.
Et à partir de ce 11, vous pouvez peut etre organiser quelque chose de plus mentalistique.
Prendre des risques sur un autre effet. Regardez dans la playlist des explications de tours, des effets qui sont sans filet.
Et vous savez qu'au final il y a une information que vous avez qui sera bonne, ce sera ce forçage mathématiques.
Deuxième chose c'est que pour que ça fonctionne, il faut qu'il vous en reste entre 10 et 20 dans la main.
Donc vous pouvez demander clairement à la personne... Oui je recule parce que ça c'est quand meme très joli.
Est ce que j'ai plus de sucres d'orge que toi ou est ce que tu en a plus que moi ?
Et en fonction de sa réponse la personne devra réduire son nombre à elle et ensuite en remettre dans votre main, et c'est vous qui aurez 11.
Ou l'inverse.
Ce n'est peut etre pas très clair dit comme ça, mais rapplelez vous de la démonstration que je viens de vous faire à l'instant.
On réduit le nombre de sucres d'orge de la personne à qui il en reste le plus.
Mais en utilisant le texte comme je l'ai utilisé, la personne n'en prendra pas beaucoup, elle en prendra moins de 10.
Troisième point mult important également, vous n'etes pas du tout obligé d'utiliser des sucres d'orge.
Vous pouvez utiliser un packet de chewing gum, vous pouvez utilsier n'improte quoi meme des choses réelles.
Le mieux c'est de le faire dans l'imaginaire comme je l'ai fait, mais utiliser l'objet que vous voulez.
Ca me faisais marrer d'utiliser des sucres d'orge parce que je me dis que vous pourrez le faire à Noel comme ça, il n'y a pas besoin d'objet, il y a besoin de rien.
Vous pouvez le faire comme ça, cash.
Concernant les forçages mathématiques je vous ai dit ne négligez pas ça, en plus c'est quand meme assez drole à pratiquer.
On peut le détourner de pleins de manières différentes.
Il y a un super bouquin que je viens de découvrir, ce ne sont pas des maths pures, c'est un peu comme ce qu'on a fait.
Ca permet de voir les choses autrement.
Je vous le mets ici en vignette, également en lien dans la description.
Et concernant le jeu que j'avais organisé lundi derrnier pour les 200  000 abonnés, et bien j'arrete les inscriptions ce soir.
Donc vous avez toujours le lien également dans la description. Ce soir c'est terminé après on va commencer à procéder aux envois.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère que ça vous a plu.
Un explication le lundi, je n'avais jamais fait ça, pourquoi pas.
Si ça vous a plu, n'hésitez pas laissez un pouce en l'air.
C'est toujours important.
Vous pouvez aussi donner vos idées de mise en scène dans les commentaires, comment vous révèleriez ce chiffre oui pourquoi pas en faisait sonner une cloche en soi. [cloche qui sonne]
Donc je disais dans les commentaires vous pouvez mettre vos idées de mise en scène, vous pouvez mettre tout ce que vous voulez, améliorer un peu l'effet, le rendre encore plus gros ou le lier à d'autres explications de tours que j'avais fait cette année la.
Portez vous bien, bons préparatifs de Noel, et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir.
Et le Mental Vlog c'est toujous une vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er janvier au 31 décembre.
Et ça ne s'arrete pas en 2017. Rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[musique]